there are a lot of uh a lot of russians
uh
like um
matlakov alexenko
matildov uh at the very least who are
who have gotten into the grand master
league in fantasy and they're doing
pretty well and uh yeah yeah
he's he's coming along well at the start
of the season i was in the top 1000
out of
nine million players so it's a big
achievement for me of course because we
obviously know magnus carlsen as well as
a good fantasy premier league player
what skills do you guys have as chess
players that make you good at fancy
premier league
[Music]
i think
is very uh he's very unpredictable
when
he chooses some players
sometimes i just can't ex
cannot expect
which players he will get
and
probably in chess as well
uh sometimes he
uh he makes some moves which no one can
expect yeah so and after your game here
in uh vikanze yeah i heard some rumors
he asked me who is my captain uh this
this game
and it was a bruno uh bruno fernandez
from manchester united and uh
he said like me too and
it was very nice so that first thing
that happened after your chess game was
fancy permanent yeah but at first we
just analyzed
some moves but the main thing of course
it was
about fantasy but you're still in the
lead
no no hammer isn't late unfortunately
all right so how's it going for you this
season the fancy for every week
[Laughter]
but it's a long way to go yeah exactly